[Musique]
on a droit de taper déjà un peu ok oui
il a un bon sont déjà j'adore le le gros
sont comme ça c'est super une joie
infinie ça nous rappelle la coupe du
monde de 2006 quand on avait battu la
france aux tirs au but en plus après 15
ans est toujours plus beau magnifique
fantastique
nous avons souffert au début mais nous
avons su garder le cap et on a gagné à
londres c'est la consternation
alors pour se rendre à wembley nina se
déclarent malades
un mensonge qui va avoir de grandes
conséquences puisque pendant le match
pas de bol nina est filmé par les
caméras en train de filmer l'égalisation
anglaise en tribunes et évidemment son
patron et devant la télé il reconnaît
immédiatement son employé les anglais
ont échoué à domicile dans leur stade 55
ans que les supporters attendaient un
nouveau trophée
j'ai beaucoup souffert dans ma vie au
travail en famille dans certaines
situations mais ça ça me prend vraiment
au triple ce n'est pas facile à gérer
c'est un jeu mais c'est plus qu'un jeu
dans ce pays le lendemain celui ci
explique dans la presse anglaise qu'il
n'a eu d'autre choix que de licencier
nina qui s'est elle aussi exprimée je
cite je ressens des émotions
contradictoires dit-elle nous sommes en
finale mais j'ai perdu mon travail des
sentiments qu'ils doivent être encore
plus contrastée ce matin après la
défaite en finale pauvre nina alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de particulièrement
masculin ce fauteuil couillard c'est
justement cette avancée pour permettre
de mettre une jambe de chaque côté
évidemment ce sont au mieux tous les
mouvements sur le plan économique le
quoi qu'il en coûte auquel je m'étais
engagé dès mars 2020 non seulement nous
a permis de protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois mais à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat de nombre de français et est à
l'origine d'un vigoureux rebond on a dit
pas de visites dans les cartes au nahd a
compris poids de vie baisse venette
m'arracher mon arme secrète
il est dur mais juste notre croissance
devrait s'établir à à 6% en 2021 en tête
des grandes économies européennes la
france pour la deuxième année
consécutive a été désigné comme le pays
le plus attractif d'europe
j'étais un enfant qui regardaient en
l'air vers les étoiles
je suis maintenant un homme dans un
vaisseau spatial qui contemple notre
belle terre en contrebas à la prochaine
génération de ravers si nous pouvons le
faire
imaginez ce que vous pouvez faire dans
un premier temps pour les personnels
soignants et non soignants des hôpitaux
des cliniques des maisons de retraite
des établissements pour personnes en
situation de handicap pour tous les
professionnels ou bénévoles qui
travaillent au contact des personnes
âgées ou fragiles y compris à domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre pour lutter qui est moins
de risques de contamination sûr que ce
qui est normal que le personnel soignant
son ex vacciner le plus grand nombre
dès la rentrée les collégiens et les
lycéens pourront faire dans les
établissements mais contrairement aux
soignants ce ne sera pas obligatoire
nous devrons sans doute nous poser la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous les français mais je fais le
choix de la confiance et j'appelle
solennellement tous nos concitoyens non
vaccinés à aller se faire vacciner dès
aujourd'hui au plus vite à partir du 21
juillet prochain plus question d'aller
voir un film au cinéma sans son pass
sanitaires une formalité utile aux yeux
de certains cinéphiles et aux rations
pour tout le monde
c'est une envie d'y aller il faut que
tout le monde fera vacciner que si on
n'impose pas certaines restrictions à
ceux qui ne le font pas voilà il y aura
pas d'amélioration de la situation
faites vous vacciner c'est la seule
façon de vous protéger et de protéger
les autres
c'est une question de responsabilité
individuelle de sens de l'esprit
collectif 7e au 6e dont dépend notre
liberté
non c'est pour ça que c'est trop tard et
puis d'ailleurs si tu machin chewing gum
tu pourrais avoir une amende et tu peux
même te faire dénoncer des sap aurait un
chewing gum
un autre passager dénonce tianjin et oui
c'est la règle ici à partir du début du
mois d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux
je suis dans les avions trains et cars
pour les longs trajets
là encore seuls les vaccinés et les
personnes testées négatives pourront
accéder à ces lieux qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs clients usagers ou salariés
je veux pas que ça me fera du bistrot
non m à 13 ans j'ai pas de maladie j'ai
rien il ya pas de micros partout
des rhodes-extérieures j'arrive j'ai
envie de prendre un verre il faut que je
prie plaisante un petit papier pour ça
on est ou quoi partout nous aurons la
même démarche reconnaître le civisme et
faire porter les restrictions sur les
non-vaccinés plutôt que sur tous
[Musique]
franchement l'impression que c'est
l'histoire sans fin
l'histoire se répète aussi pour les
professionnels déjà durement touchée
ce théâtre par exemple devra contrôler
lui-même chacun de ses spectateurs
après moi je suis directeur de théâtre
je ne vois pas refuser quelqu'un à
l'entrée d'un une salle de la salle de
spectacle pour un spectacle parce qu'il
n'a pas le bon qr codes ou donc ça va
être compliqué oui
comme ce sens là guy joseph hennon
mécanique les jeunes
bien qu'on fasse on est l'intérêt c'est
ça que je veux savoir à quel est
l'intérêt et l'attention
non mais quel est l'intérêt pourquoi
fait ça au quatrième étage de cet
immeuble un homme barricadé chez lui
jette par dessus son balcon tout ce qui
lui tombe sous la main
vaisselle bouteilles en verre ou manche
d'aspirateurs la rue est coupée et sous
ses fenêtres des dizaines d'objets
recouvre la chaussée poubelles coussin
chaise ou même des journaux en feu une
france unie qui sait être solidaire
civique responsable dans l'épreuve comme
dans la conquête
vive la république et vive la france